a step forward for the woman charged
with salvaging Britain's biggest
business Lobby group armed with a
thumping mandate to reform the
scandalized CBI I think a majority of 93
is one that any politician would respect
and I think what we've shown today is
that we've got the support of our
members and now we want to sit down with
policy makers look at the economic
evidence look at the insights we're
getting from businesses and talk to them
about the critical challenges our
economy faces the CBI has been cut
adrift by some members and ministers
following claims of a toxic culture and
two allegations of rape and unconnected
misconduct claims against former
director General Tony danker that cost
him his job at an extraordinary general
meeting the remaining members delivered
a thumping mandate for reform asked do
the changes we've made to reform our
governance culture and purpose give you
the confidence you need to support the
CBI 93 voted yes and just seven percent
no from 371 votes cast business has been
very much about profit and about you
know the bottom line well now we
actually have to look at culture we have
to look at behaviors I think we're
showing they've really addressed these
particular issues and but you don't want
to throw the baby out with the bath
water and destroy the good parts Blue
Chip companies like NatWest BT and John
Lewis that resigned their membership are
not rushing to return leaving the CBI
short of cash as well as credibility so
this member has faith in the leadership
it's not a culture that I recognized and
it's not the people that I recognized
the people that I know at the CBI and
that's you know a lot of the reason why
I'm standing here today is because of my
personal connection and personal trust
in each and every one of the people that
are at the CBI today the cbi's challenge
now is to try to win back the trust of
some of the biggest companies in Britain
that walked away when this Scandal broke
and to regain credibility in Westminster
so that ministers and the opposition
start talking to it again you can't have
one without the other and the CBI needs
both if it's to regain its position
the CBI hopes to again lead British
business having offered an object lesson
in what can go wrong
Paul Kelso Sky News